michael a shy 13 year old boy is in love
with stella after wearing a costume to a
halloween party he discovers that he can
turn invisible so today on cinema
recapped i'll show you
the invisible boy the film begins with a
man who is drawing on a wall what seems
to be some kind of city suddenly he
collapses and a mysterious man appears
and sees the drawing
we can see that it is a representation
of a city where our protagonist michael
lives
he wanted to buy a costume in the store
but it was closed
the boy hides his money in his shoe and
goes to school where we can see that
there are a few classmates who bully him
and one of them is very big since he has
been held back several years they are
brando and ivan
we see that michael likes to record
videos of a girl in his class named
stella
but the bullies notice this and begin to
pick on him about it at that moment a
female police officer named jovana
arrives and tells everyone that there is
a missing child and that if someone
knows something they should let her know
immediately we also notice that this
lady is also michael's mother since in
front of everyone she hands him his
lunch
when michael's mother leaves the other
students make fun of him he gets a
bloody nose and he asks for permission
to go to the bathroom to wash it off
then the school bell rings and michael
tries to hide in one of the bathrooms
where the bullies can't find him but
they find him and drag him out they take
away his money that he had saved for the
costume they threaten him with the
paintball gun and he runs around the
school so they don't shoot them however
they managed to land a shot and if it
wasn't enough one of them even steps on
his hand the poor boy runs home and sad
about what happened and then we meet a
girl named candela who is michael's
younger sister
because of what had happened at school
he does not want to see his mother
michael goes to the costume store to see
if he can find a superhero one just like
the one he found at the other store
then he shows up owner the little money
he has to see what he could afford with
the cash
the owner shows him the costume of a
supposedly very famous superhero
and although the boy isn't very
convinced about it he buys it anyway
back home michael watches a video left
by the boy who disappeared a few days
ago in which he says that he left
because he was fed up with his life
there later on michael's mother comes
home and finds her son on the couch
wearing the cheap costume that he bought
giovanna asked him why is he not at the
costume party he was supposed to go to
the boy tells her that the costume is
horrible and that he will not go to the
party like that after they talk for a
while she convinces him to go to the
party and have fun when michael arrives
at the party he sees a girl he likes and
although he had not dared to speak to
her before that night they exchanged
some words suddenly the boys start
playing some videos on the tv and stella
approaches and sees that the videos are
of her in different shots
she's confused asked for explanations
and one of the bullies tell her that
those were taken from videos from
michael's cell phone
stella goes to michael and asks if this
is true the boy gets scared he can't
speak and decides to just run away some
of the other children scare him and he
locks himself in the room and screams at
a mirror saying he wants to become
invisible
[Music]
the next day he wakes up in bed still
with the costume on
he takes it off goes to bathe as usual
however when he gets out of the shower
and brushes his teeth he stands in front
of the mirror and cannot see his
reflection he leaves the bathroom and
tries to see himself in a larger mirror
but finds out that he is completely
invisible
the mother enters the room but she
cannot see him
and he leaves her a note so she won't
get worried he puts on several layers of
clothing and goes out to the street he
wants to go to school but when he sees
that he's still invisible he decides to
just go home but before leaving he sees
one of his bullies and decides to take
off all his clothes so no one sees him
and takes his revenge he enters the
school naked but of course no one can
see him when he's in the classroom he
takes ivan's paintball gun and shoots at
the board the teacher gets very upset
reports ivan and calls his parents
michael then goes to mess with brando
who is playing the tennis game and he
causes him to lose
so his father scolds him for not winning
the bully then gets sad however
michael's not finished yet he follows
brando to the locker room and scares him
with the ball making him run away and
screaming for help then michael decides
to go home he gets his bike and then he
sees ivan's father who went to the
school since the principal had called
him talk about the boy's behavior with
his paintball gun in the class we can
see how ivan's father mistreats him and
tells him that he's in big trouble when
he gets home at that moment we see a
girl pass by
after doing some exercise and is on her
way to the showers
and of course michael follows the girl
to the showers while he's just sitting
there watching them all including stella
one of them throws a towel and it falls
on him
at that moment the girls stare at him
since they don't know who's under the
towel
michael gets nervous and we can see how
his hands gradually begin to be visible
one of the girls slowly removes a towel
and everyone can see that it's michael
under it so they all come out of the
shower screaming michael's mother talks
to him to try to understand why he did
what he did
the next day in class they are visited
by a psychologist who working for the
police some of the children give michael
a weird look because of what had
happened yesterday michael notices his
hands begin to disappear again and the
psychologist almost finds out but the
bell rings and the boy runs out he
arrives home but candela's in his room
so she ends up discovering that he is
invisible
michael asked her to keep a secret
the sibling tried to figure out where
the invisibility powers come from the
sister tells him that he should be a
superhero and help people in need
michael is confused at this
the cops are trying to find out why
there's children going missing and we
see that brando has also disappeared
meanwhile jovanna is looking for her son
but he's using his power so she can't
see him jovana answers the call while
michael overhears what she is talking
about the boy realizes that he is
adopted since the mother confesses it on
the phone
michael goes out to sit on a swing for a
while stella arrives and sees a swing
moving by itself and approaches it
curiously
she sits on the swing on the side and
michael tells her that he is an angel
and draws a happy face on the sand
stella asks if he wants to be her friend
and then says goodbye mike was happy
about what happened but at the same time
he's sad about his mother's words
the next day in class the boy can see
that stella still thinks about the
invisible boy
michael goes to stella's house at night
he comes in and they talk for a while
the girl's mother almost discovers them
they kiss and michael starts to get
nervous and visible again so he runs out
of there
candela tells her brother that he needs
to confess his feelings to stella and
that he is the invisible boy that she
likes michael makes up his mind and goes
to where stella trains gymnastics to
confess his secret to her
suddenly the girl is put to sleep with
tranquilizer darts and then some
strangers kidnap her michael wants to
rescue her but he can't stop them the
police arrive at the scene and they
thank him for trying to help the girl
then we see how the kidnappers do
experiments with stella
and one of them says that she's not the
one they're looking for meanwhile the
siblings try to make the suit work with
candela but it doesn't michael confronts
his mother and they argue in the end the
boy tells her that he is not his mother
and he leaves a place riding his bike
very fast with a lot of resentment
meanwhile we see that stella brando and
the other boy were kidnapped at the same
men
a blind man talks to michael and tells
him that he is his father and that he
also has powers which is to read minds
he tells them that a long time ago there
were some people with powers just like
them and that they were manipulated by
an organization called the division who
wanted to use them as weapons
in there he met his wife and conceived
michael but the division took the child
away for their experiments so they
decided to escape from there the mother
sacrificed herself during the escape and
we see that her power was invisibility
which michael inherited after telling
the story the father reads a stranger's
mind and finds out that he wants to call
the police since he thinks he wants to
kidnap michael so the father simply
erases his memory since that's one of
his other powers
he also gives michael a gift which is a
suit that adapts to his invisibility
powers jovana talks to michael and the
psychiatrist tells her that he will take
him home
on the other hand stella begins to come
up with ways of escaping
psychologists takes michael home and
wants to talk with him but the boy
begins to suspect of him and quickly
discovers that he is the one kidnapping
the children so he runs and prepares to
use his powers
then he tries to hit the psychiatrist
who is actually part of the division but
he manages to catch the kid however
michael performs some maneuvers to get
rid of him and runs on ivan's motorcycle
he tells him to go because a
psychiatrist wants to kill them then
michael confesses his identity to
giovanna and comes home and is surprised
by all the mess stella and the other
children managed to leave the room
meanwhile michael and ivan prepare to
save their friends stella sends a signal
to michael so that they know where they
are both children go to the place where
the signal is however the kidnappers
catch stella again and lock her up ivan
manages to distract the guards while
michael goes to save the kids he steals
a gun and takes the boys out however
before leaving zelo tells him that they
also have to save an old man the other
boys escape while we find out that
stella was being controlled by a man in
a wheelchair who can control minds whose
name is gara
michael goes invisible and starts
beating the kidnappers but he stops
because they threaten to kill stella we
also see that they're in the submarine
that's moving meanwhile we see that
michael's father jovana and ivan are
trying to find michael and the other
children
they only save brando and the other boy
before the place explodes while the
others are stuck in a submarine on its
way to russia
[Music]
gara is trying to convince the boy to go
with him by telling him that his
mother's alive and she sent them to go
look for him michael does not believe
him and he suddenly uses a strange power
to kill them all then he and stella
escape from the submarine they arrive
with the others the father tells michael
that he will have to erase everyone's
memory so they don't know anything about
michael's powers but before he does that
michael says goodbye to stella and soon
no one remembers anything
giovanna is credited for rescuing the
kidnapped kids michael returns to school
and the bullies try to annoy him again
but he just ignores them since he got to
know them better before losing their
memory
the boy goes with stella and somehow she
remembers him and they talk very happily
in the end we see michael's mother was
not dead we also find out that she has
two children michael and natasha
and she's looking for both of them
the end if you liked the video please
leave a like and subscribe to continue
receiving recap to the best superhero
movies my name is tc and i'll see you in
the next video bye